week six show me something draft peter
i'm gonna give you the first pick who do
you have
uh show me something daniel jones
um
so mike
in preparing my diligent preparation you
know i spent hours and hours uh working
in preparing for this show
yeah i wanted to i wanted to tell you
one thing about daniel jones
his touchdown to interception
differential
is minus three all right two touchdowns
five interceptions all right
mitchell trubisky is plus three
and you know
at some point at some point
all the other things about well i got a
lousy offensive line well i only got
darius slayton and golden tate i don't
have a lot of weapons evan ingram is
never healthy you know
at some point
the quarterback has to lift his team
that point
is sunday against washington
if the new york giants fall to 016 and
there's another clunker by daniel jones
there will be legitimate questions about
whether dave gettleman picked the right
quarterback period
yeah i agree with you completely and and
look if they are in position to get
trevor lawrence uh yeah you have to you
have to do it you have to do it no
matter where daniel jones is because he
hasn't been the guy that i think they
thought he was going to be and at some
point he's got to step up and show that
he can do it regardless of any excuses
that can be put out there to explain why
he's not getting it done
i'm going with josh allen for the reason
we discussed earlier in the hour because
right now after what happened the bills
on tuesday night we don't know who they
are we don't know where josh allen
currently is and he needs to prove that
tuesday night was an aberration and he
needs to prove he can go toe-to-toe with
patrick mahomes they talk all the time
in chest partially about who's got the
stronger arm and let's have a
competition and who knows maybe they'll
hang around after the game and do it but
this is his chance prime time sort of uh
it was gonna be a thursday night game
now it's a monday night early game and
this is josh allen's chance to prove
that whatever it was that happened in
nashville is a fluke and not where he is
and not where his team is peter
no question about it and look as we said
earlier one of the things about josh
allen is
you know his first four games of this
season he was a different player
there was a regression
in week five
and if that regression continues
then there's going to be a lot of
questions about josh allen i don't think
we should look at
this game as anything other than one
game for right now
uh
weird that it seemed like an emotional
game uh without any fans in the stands
but this was this was a game where it
looked like josh allen got away from
what he had been doing and he wasn't as
accurate as he was he made some bad
decisions which he hadn't been making so
you've got to basically just give him a
mulligan for this game
i agree with you but we'll see what
happens in the next game because the
narrative may emerge if he lays another
egg against the chiefs all right peter
round two who you got
all right show me something nick saban
stay home and let your team play without
you if indeed your team is going to play
and i realize this is a professional
football show
but nick saban is a professional
football coach
and
if you get covid19
you can't just say well i'm asymptomatic
i feel fine and try to figure out a way
to go and coach your team and again i
don't know what's going to happen i'm
not following the story closely i just
know that nick saban's place on saturday
night if this game is played number two
georgia number three alabama that he
should be in his living room watching on
tv with
i guess a decreasing number of fans
watching sports on tv these days but he
should be watching on tv and getting
better and planning to come back to his
team
and i respect how driven he is and i
respect how motivated he is and i
respect the fact that he's still working
deep into his 60s and he probably won't
stop anytime soon and he shows up every
day and punches the clock and does what
needs to be done but there's a point
where what needs to be done is set an
example for the other people out there
who are still very confused because of
all the mixed signals they're getting
about the proper behavior in situations
like this so i agree with you peter next
one for me
tommy show me something show me you can
count to four show me that you can go
toe to toe with a guy who may be more
physically gifted than you this is a
huge game for the buccaneers they're in
a three-way tie with the panthers and
the saints atop the division none of
those three teams look great
they need to show and brady needs to
show that he's exactly the guy the
buccaneers thought they were getting
peter
and you know he will take all of that to
heart what he's heard and read and and
and everything because even though tom
brady's got six super bowl wins he's
motivated by everything
he is a normal human being who plays in
the nfl other than the fact he's got six
rings but he listens to things he knows
what is being said out there so he will
be properly motivated they don't i'll
give you my name outside noise they
don't listen to outside noise
[Laughter]
go ahead i'll give you i'll give you my
next one mike my next one is
show me something houston texans
okay if you really are this new team in
the wake of the firing of bill o'brien
and you just love the the you know sort
of the the kid glove approach of romeo
cornell show me something by going into
tennessee and playing toe to toe and
making it a two minute warning game in
the fourth quarter you you love deshawn
watson play great for desean watson in a
game you've really got no business
winning
show me something houston texans hey
that's the thing you take away the 42-16
win on tuesday night the titans had not
been impressive in any of their wins
against lesser teams so there's an
opportunity there for the texans to to
prove that they do have something more
than what we saw when they beat the
jaguars last one for me alexander
madison
who had a great game on sunday night
both before dalvin cook was injured and
after but show me something specifically
show me that you can hit an 18-foot hole
show me show me that you can that you
can identify an opening between
defensive lineman large enough to land a
plane
uh you know look and and i'm sure he's
heard that all week dalvin cook would
have made that run there it is cpd got a
squint to see the hole that he missed
it's very it's very hard to see i'm glad
we're ending the week with this we
started the week with it we're ending
the week with it
i mean i'm seriously where's the 747
that's gonna land right there but but
look hooks out with the groin injury he
won't play this is madison's chance his
first nfl start and redemption coming
for him and good reason for it after the
way sunday's game ended peter
alexander madison to me when i watch him
play he reminds me so much of dalvin
cook he is a physical
physically bruising running back he
loves contact mike i think he's going to
rise to the occasion if they play this
game i think he's going to have a very
big game against the falcons
and i got a feeling that that mike
zimmer
a bill parcells disciple has been
needling alexander madison a little bit
this week about that faithful play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports